and be known from South Stockton you
catch me on the bootleg Kev uh podcast
special guest in here representing
Stockton man MB Nails in the building
you know so true so true thank you for
pulling up buddy I'm for sure yeah how's
everything in your world man good just
been working still focused yeah you
happy you feel like you're always
working bro yeah yeah I'm trying to get
right do you feel like uh because I
always say this man I feel like Stockton
is like kind of like
the hottest city in California in terms
of the hip-hop scene and what's going on
and I feel like
it seems like like y'all finally kind of
getting some credit now do you feel that
way
yeah yeah for sure it's definitely a lot
of talent out there and everyone just
starting to get hip it's been like that
for a couple years now but yeah it's
dope to see for sure yeah I feel like
you're kind of when I think of Stockton
I think of you and I think a Haiti baby
like in terms like the last five years
like you guys are kind of like the the
two main dudes dude is that fair to say
yeah I think that's fair to say for sure
what is up man look I ain't trying to
get into no politics but it feels like
there's just a lot of drama in terms
between the rappers out there whether
it's yourself and other guys and you
know it just seems like there's a lot of
um
like not a lot of people moving together
out there yeah definitely not is that
like uh it's all politic driven
yeah definitely it's it's a budget
street
that that that you know hinders music
for sure I feel like La that kind of got
in the way of La kind of moving because
you know there was a moment when La was
kind of like cold you know what I mean
yeah I feel like because a lot of the up
and coming artists out of LA
let the politics I guess get in the way
of the music now Stockton's a way
different city some very small place
yeah so it's definitely not the same
dynamic because I'm sure
when [__] happens in Stockton it's very
small I've been there you know small
everybody went to school together yeah
related it's a lot different right yeah
but for you like do you think that
there's any
like progress in the right direction or
is it still kind of like everyone just
kind of divided doing their own thing
[Music]
um
I mean
as of right now people like that [__]
though like like I feel that's what's
driving it like people like seeing that
that beefing yeah and that drama
yeah it's crazy because I kind of feel
like Stockton's kind of like the West
Coast like Jacksonville kind of like
Jacksonville's like rap scene is like
kind of driven by like beef and I feel
like yeah the stock is kind of similar
like it's just so much beef and I feel
like it helps it's not good for the
human beings involved not but it helps
with it helps with the with the getting
the streams up and numbers up for sure
especially like YouTube and stuff
it's like a give and a take though
because it's like if you lean into that
there's like real life ramifications
yeah yeah for sure you gotta know what
you signed up for yeah but yeah
that's that's that's what people like
right now do you feel like you be
leaning in there a little bit just to
kind of help the music or
I mean I always been a type like
whatever whatever be happening I just
leave it out the music because I I I
treat it like two separate entities you
feel me like this is really my job
through like like business you feel me
like I don't wanna
it ain't I I just I try to just do like
look at it professionally you feel me
yeah but and as far as that I'm just
yeah for sure yeah I mean there's been a
lot of guys losing their life out there
too man like you know like the like the
slowby dude obviously rest in peace but
a lot of a lot of dudes there
I feel like I've heard a few people
losing their life out there they're like
I just follow the fizzler Bro The
Sizzler just be keeping me yeah it's not
what the stock is yeah for sure
um for you because you're kind of like
one of the Pioneers out there I would
say that you're probably in terms of
like catalog and like you know being
able to tour and do certain [__]
you're probably the most successful guy
out of Stockton do you feel any pressure
or any responsibility kind of being like
the national face of a city like that uh
yeah a little bit about to save time
it's just I really just be so like
worried about myself like I don't really
care what what
how what people expect or you feel me
think of me it's just I'm just so
focused and dialed in on on myself and
try to like better myself so other
people look at that like as a
as a you know a good representation it's
just it is what it is you feel me
naturally
when do you feel like you kind of like
figured out how to like properly
turn the Rapture into a business and
like really monetize your fan base
uh I started I started looking in the
analytics everything like where where
certain fans listening to music from uh
like top cities like what type of like
I'm really looking at what type of songs
is streaming the most you feel me like
like certain rap songs is do good on
YouTube but then like a like a song
that's for the females like singing
melodizing that's that's doing hella
good on like like Spotify or something
and I'm looking at and it's like cities
that I never expected so like where
like right now my Spotify list last time
I looked at it I think
top five I think it was like Melbourne
Australia London
uh it was like three out of country
cities oh [__] yeah and it'd be like
it'd be like for songs like like the the
the singing songs you feel me that's so
crazy to think like Australia's really
far hello
so when you see some [__] like that or
you're like damn maybe we should try to
go do some shows out there or
run some ads out there try to you know
like like how do you take that
information and like how do you apply it
to like what you're doing
uh yeah we try to we try to do like try
to try to have ads reach towards towards
that way
um
we we were actually speaking to somebody
from out there like a promoter trying to
get some shows together
but uh that's on hold right now trying
to put that together uh try to have a
show in Canada and then
and they didn't even let me in which was
weird because they let me in in uh
Toronto and uh Montreal is it because of
your record yeah but but it did me so
greasy this time like they looked at
everything like
they even uh bro couldn't even get any
they was bringing up stuff from like
when he was 14. really crazy was this
Vancouver yeah Vancouver damn so like
you how does it work you get to the
border so yeah we get over there we go
through the little uh I forgot what it's
called uh what's it called when you go
we would go to TJ Customs Customs yeah
so we win customs
um
they see me whatever I guess I guess I
kind of throw them off with the face
tattoos
uh they they looked me up I guess they
seen I was a rapper then they look up
everything else that's on the internet
the indict the the little indictment
just that was on like blogs and all that
so all that pop up
they on everything I on my on my two
suitcases I got two bandanas on it just
to identify it right and so you know
when you yeah yeah you know what I'm
saying but but they happen to be blue so
they asking why is why is it blue I'm
like that's the that's the first thing I
see I just put it on there yeah but
they have they bring me to like a little
room in the back
they're like we gotta ask you a couple
questions
I'm like all right whatever
bro they have me in there for like
eight hours eight hours bro just add
like like damn you're interrogating me
just to deny you well I hope my whole
life like asking me about my whole life
like everything like
go back to the waiting room
all right there's a couple more
questions we gotta ask go back in here
for like two hours I go back to the
waiting room
they had me doing that back and forth
and then and then the day was coming to
an end there was nobody else coming in
there was like
um
uh based on the information you gave us
we still got to do some more research
like more stuff come up
so I'm like damn they're like uh it
might be a it might be a a a legal issue
now because you're they're trying to say
I was an active fan you feel me just a
little [__] like that now now it's a
legal issue and I'm like a legal issue
like like what are you talking about I
instantly called I actually called Matt
who's a lawyer and yeah the lawyer and
my real lawyer right uh uh mark
so I called in they get in contact with
them trying to see what's up uh uh Mark
and Matt get a hold of it uh the uh was
it the embassy or something like that
trying to talk to them uh they're like
you're gonna have to spend the night in
uh in custody so we could do more
homework on you what the [__] yeah just
to try to get into a country yeah I was
like yeah I gotta go they're like you
can't leave there's no there's unless
you can find a flood there's like we'll
give you an exception if you could find
a flight to the US right now we'll let
you leave but they were like there isn't
any though so you're gonna have to spend
the night and it could possibly become a
legal issue because you're organized uh
what they say gang member that's coming
into the country or something like that
so I'm looking I'm like give me five
minutes bro I'll find a flight right now
so we looking there I'm on the three-way
with Matt and a lawyer and we're just
trying to find a flight to get up out of
there the first flight I see it was in
New York so I just bought a ticket to
New York got up out of there what bro I
was there for so long yeah just to get
it so you were trying to drive like you
drove to the Border or did you fly there
we flew so you fly into Vancouver to the
airport and before they let you into the
country they pretty much hit you with
the line of course yeah so
so when I first went to uh Toronto uh
the dude kind of gave me a little bit of
issue I got in contact with my lawyer
kind of but uh but the dude was cool so
what they were saying it really depend
on who's working at the time right but I
guess Vancouver more uh strict because
uh it's connected to California you feel
me right damn that's crazy so you just
flew to New York yeah flew to New York
spent the night over there and had to
fly back that [__] is well I was on a
plane for like a whole day that sounds
like a terrible 24th terrible 32 hours
terrible do you um do you find that like
you know some of your history does it
hinder the way people look at you
sometimes or some of your opportunities
ever
uh outside of Canada
yeah I feel like it sometimes
excuse me
uh
yeah I feel like it sometimes yeah like
is it like because for you I feel like
you've been kind of like leveling up in
terms of like I just noticed the way you
move you're moving a lot different
you're moving more like a businessman
like
um
It's gotta suck to kind of like you know
that stigma just follow you around I'm
like bro I'm like a artist who's like
I'm not like some local rapper yeah I'm
not some gang member who sucks at
rapping and I do this as a hobby you
know what I mean yeah I actually had a
uh I had a couple talks with a couple uh
I had a couple sit-downs with some
labels like a couple years ago probably
like two years ago and then
they just they just looking at like I
don't know how we supposed to Market him
is it it's a Filipino dude it was a [__]
like there's we don't know how it's
gonna fit with anything rap like so it's
it's just all type of stuff yeah you uh
it's funny because you and uh uh
you know I feel like
there is kind of a
I feel like hip-hop doesn't know how to
figure out the West Coast
Asian gang member rap thing yet even
though you know people have gotten
plaques you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah for sure you gotta go plaque yet
uh not yet but I got one that's that's
close to one of my other songs feelings
which can go on a pillow crazy for some
reason just out of nowhere yeah Tick
Tock I don't know what it is I don't
even be on Tick Tock so I don't know
it's crazy because like you'll see a
record like that's like
three or four years old like just yeah
blow up blowing up out of nowhere dude
it'd be like this crazy even like stupid
young [__] like it was dope to see him
get I mean get get uh I think Mando went
gold or platinum I think it would
Platinum yeah you guys did uh tape
together yeah we did two yellow tape
right yeah did you guys do a yellow tape
part too and I just missed it
probably uh yeah yeah you guys running
back for the trio
uh we've been talking about it
was that something you guys kind of
related on just kind of being Asians and
like I mean northern California Southern
California yeah yeah we just and and uh
when he uh he he know he knows Folks at
Stockton Avenue you really mean like and
like some people from itself is in
Stockton and I knew some people and you
just kind of as I say the politics
between Asians from the south of the
north are not the same as like Mexicans
right
because it feels like the gang [__] if
you're if you're a southerner or a
northerner and you're from like the
Mexican [__] it feels like super divided
the way you see what I think that's
really only the north days and cereals
for real right but but on the Asian tip
it's not like no it's not like that it's
really it's really like where you from
for real yeah shout out to the Filipinos
are doing well right now man my you know
Nico Blitz he's my producer yeah he's
like Mr Filipino hip-hop you know yeah
yeah has he done a like a mix of your
songs yet on his Tick Tock uh you got to
press him for that maybe I don't know
like I said I want to be on Tick Tock so
I don't know I think I see that one time
but I'm not sure yeah yeah no he's a big
fan listen do you want to win some money
gotta stop the interview but listen
there's so many opportunities to gamble
to bet on your favorite sports to make
Sports more interesting NFL season is
over but it's all good because the
opportunities to win are just getting
started you yeah look there's so many
things you can do we're talking about
NCAA NBA NHL UFC boxing there's
Blackjack tournaments so much money to
get in on and check this out y'all if
you sign up right now using the promo
code bootleg do it right now you can get
a welcome bonus up to a thousand dollars
plus you're gonna get a free 150
000 March Madness bracket contest entry
that's
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
right now get a bonus up to a thousand
dollars you're gonna put in 200 bucks
they could give you 200 you put in a
thousand they'll give you another
thousand right look right now go to
mybookie.ag sign up use that promo code
March Madness is upon us so much great
Sports just NBA season playoffs are on
the way man you could like literally put
together some crazy props like uh I
don't know over under on a player that
you like scoring you could do a future
on the MVP do you think jokic is going
to win it you think Joel embiid is going
to win it whatever it is get in on the
action right now mybookie.ag with that
promo code bootleg when you sign up get
that free deposit bonus all right bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
also shout out to our family at hardean
Hardy in Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot
them a follow on Instagram while you're
at it go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com so much fly gear so
much fly weed what are we talking about
baby shout out to hardine man that's the
family man go if you're in Vegas pull up
on them man Jardine Las Vegas do you
feel like uh Filipinos are coming up in
rap right now
yourself
[Music]
uh yeah but like
they make different music though you get
what I'm saying I feel like it's like
I come from a from a Different Cloth
yeah like yeah different world yeah for
real yeah they're making like more
commercially palatable [__] you're
making like gangster rap you know what
I'm saying but I'm trying to do that
commercial [__]
how's it working now you think your fans
are like receptor do that kind of [__]
uh some of them and some of them not but
it's crazy because like like I was
saying I pay attention to Analytics so
like my my more uppity like mainstream
sound of songs that do really good on
streaming and but then but then it's
fans that want the you know the old type
of music
but you just gotta balance it because
you can't please everybody you feel me
and you can't box yourself you gotta
want to grow yeah
do you uh I just saw Russ talked about
how YouTube videos are not music videos
rather aren't as important as they once
were
uh and you have a lot of videos your
YouTube following is pretty big do you
feel like you're getting the same like
Roi that you used to get when you drop a
music video
uh
yeah but
but I'm just starting to like pay
attention to the different streaming
services and it really is a different
Dynamic uh
different kind of fans that that listen
to different streaming stuff so
like uh
I've been noticing like on YouTube
they've been liking more like the more
rapping rapping [__] and the streaming
more more commercial stuff yeah yeah
because YouTube is free you know what
I'm saying and streaming stuff is it's
probably more like older young adults or
teenagers or some who who could pay for
this treatment services the monthlies
and stuff like you know
uh talk about the muddy boys man what's
what's the uh yeah obviously that's your
crew what's the origins of of the money
boys
uh yeah it's just you family with your
brothers family we all came from the
same area
uh grew up off 8th Street
um and that was that we really just this
is It's just Collective just Bros yeah
do you feel like uh is that like what is
this a label or is it just the crew uh
label I'm trying to make it a label
sign artists yeah do you feel like uh
you you could be a CEO
man that's all that's that's what I'm
trying to that's what I'm trying to grow
into yeah for sure man
um who would you put in like the top
three or four artists in Stockton right
now
uh right now
uh I say the Bros I'm I'm philanth
supporting the Bros so
uh
Joe Murray
Twan uh
got the homie be nice working I'm just
finished supporting the Bros
ciao heady baby just signed with Jeezy
oh [__] out Haiti baby though too he's
doing the [__] he just hang with CTE
yeah another upcoming artist pretty low
pink but
yeah you know who's dope too is uh Dawn
Quest oh yeah he's dope too he can rap
his ass off oh yeah for sure not [__]
with donkeys and he's Filipino yeah
y'all [__] with him heavy yeah I just I
just mentioned I just mentioned the
homies feel me I just mentioned the
homies but but yeah it's a lot of
telling out there yo as a Filipino did
you ever eat what's this [__] called
with the baby egg embryo it starts with
a B
uh but look have you had that I never
eat this you've never tried it
um why not
all right it's not my thing that thing
with crazy
it's like it's like a half born like
chicken right is it like an embryo so my
mom be eating that right so your mom
eats it yeah you never tried it
never tried I I think I did actually
like the soup the part like the yolk
part yeah like like but you didn't take
it apart you didn't take a bite of the
chicken uh I don't think I don't know
the people I know who eat it don't eat
the actual embryo they just drink the
soup okay I don't know
Jesus yeah that's what's crazy I love to
be gone and everything I love that I
love Filipino food but that's the one
thing I can't ever try it looks crazy
like I love lumpia I mean I love I love
Filipino food there's this place in Daly
City there's a casino
uh and they have this Filipino Diner in
there have you been to Daly City it's
like a little bit yeah I've been here
I've been a lot of times there's this
like little there's a casino it's called
like a lucky something casino and they
got this Filipino Diner in that [__] is
[__] gas but I can't [__] with the
half born baby uh crazy there's some of
them they cracked the egg open hey
biggest [__] have you got to go develop
have you been to the Philippines yet to
like perform or like you know no I've
been there when I was a kid like I think
I was like like nine or something I
thought you gotta pull up and shoot a
video over there man I want to just
don't bring any drugs for sure being
killed the president don't play
over no coming back I just watched the
Netflix documentary about the Filipino
prisons and their most crowded prisons
in the world
it's terrible it's just Fool's on top of
each other smoking weed yeah and that's
for weed it was wild it's crazy man do
you feel like
um
because you relocated out of Stockton
right yeah I got us I I got two spots I
got one that's out the way I got a spot
by the city do you feel like it's kind
of necessary for you to kind of make
sure to kind of I feel like I hate it
when I see like to go back yeah it's
like bro I just don't I just don't I
don't know if it's necessary because you
kind of put yourself in the In Harm's
Way for no reason just to say like yeah
I'm good over here you know what I mean
oh yeah definitely definitely that's uh
why hinder yourself
to do something like you can support
from a distance but but me really I was
just
um
it's just it's just more to it family
and I'm trying to like you know uh
looking up into some business and stuff
out there I actually uh invested in with
the
one of the homies on uh on a dispensary
oh [__] stuck there but uh more details
on that later but I went in on that so
we will have a dispensary open in
Stockton uh just some just some stuff
I'm trying to look into like this
restaurant like a family-owned
restaurant just just [__] like that
almost like put the money back into the
city but they don't mean you got to be
it's living there you know what I mean
yeah yeah yeah
because you know the biggest haters
everybody got from where they're from
for sure
you just got you just got to maneuver
right yeah would you ever uh I was gonna
say because you've obviously been
successfully independent for a very long
time would you ever have like that
you know if you had the opportunity to
sign a major deal would you ever
consider it
uh yeah definitely
because at the end of the day
like if the bet if the bag is right and
the terms are right like uh like why not
you know what I'm saying like like I
said it depends on the terms though if
it's like oh take everything that you
currently own type [__] or or if it's
just all strictly with new music or like
I said it depends on terms got to be
right yeah the terms got to be right bad
Gotta Be Right terms got to be right all
that yeah because if you if you smart
you just reinvest the money or just you
ain't like just don't blow it you know
what I'm saying for sure but uh when's
the new album dropping
uh we don't have an exact date yet but
we have I have an EP drop in this month
on the 17th uh it's called start in the
South that's just a little some held
over the fans how many records six six
records any features uh with OTF Duty
low okay
um
and then yeah in the album I got some
big features on there right very cool I
go sir I can't say right now that'll
probably be hot but but I got some big
features on there when you say big what
do you mean by big big
some big features not the average not
not average
how you link up with with the OTF guys
with Duty though so I just reached out
did you have to like is that a feature
you got to pay for you guys just kind of
do a swapper I reached I was crazy I
reached out on uh
Instagram
and just went about like that
he just sent it over
uh we just chopping it up and then uh he
had left Empire after I forgot what
label he is with right now but uh had
left the Empire so we had to get the
lawyers involved and stuff like that
paperwork it's a lot easier when
everyone's on Empire and just like yeah
we on the same [__] bro yeah yeah
uh so the so the the album albums got
some big features
Big features what city are the big
features from
but like Daryl self Atlanta
uh around that region Memphis
yeah around that region
I'm fishing right now man what do you
want from me
so you gotta you got a song with uh with
glow really coming
I'm just I'm just pulling names
she's hard bruh she's like one of the
only female rappers that I could like
[__] listen to and not be like
like black I'm not bumping sweetie in
the car yeah and I love sweetie God
bless her but my wife is listening to
sweetie I'm not [__] listening to
sweetie she's talking about [__]
dudes for burkins and [__] I can't
relate to that [__] yeah well really
[__] she kind of sounds like a dude you
know
yeah so you could kind of like trick
yourself into being like yeah I feel you
bro even though she's a girl you know
yeah not sure yeah who's your uh like
would you say your biggest influences
are just in general man when it comes to
like rapping
in general uh
probably probably Lil Wayne or something
like Louanne Wayne
uh like a mix of Wayne and nipsy Wayne
and nip like wayne style nip mindset did
you meet nip when he was alive no I
didn't damn
he was a good dude hey we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our good
Folks at Blue chew baby that's right A
lot of people keep asking me does
Bluetooth work [__] yeah it does and if
you don't believe me they'll give you a
whole month for free right now if you go
to bluetooth.com and use that promo code
bootleg that's bootry.com promo code
bootleg you get a month of blue chew for
free delivered to your [__] house all
you do is pay five dollars in shipping
what is blue tree you ask well let me
tell you it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis in a
chewable tablet but it is discreetly
delivered right to your doorstep no
awkward doctor's visits imagine going
and telling uh an old guy about your
dick
you would prefer not to do that I know
I'd prefer not to do that you know but
you could do it all online bluetooth.com
you don't have to go to the doctor's
appointment in person no more no they're
going to send it straight to your door
all right your wife won't even know it
came your wife won't know
that you came and it came all right so
what you do is
you uh you go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg and you get a month
of uh the whole thing for free that's
right a month supply of Bluetooth for
free straight to your door they also
just dropped their new mint chewable
which is the same exact active
ingredient as Levitra so many options
for you at Bluetooth to make sure your
dick is right going into the springtime
baby look spring break's coming uh are
you gonna be coming
the real question is
is your partner going to be coming
not with the noodle dick
let's be honest make sure that shit's
hard as [__]
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and get a month's supply for
free and if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it's okay man
it happens to the best of us go to
Bluetooth and put a Band-Aid on that
thing bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
also
while we're talking about our partners
shout out to our family at Odd Socks oh
look at these Odd Socks underwear man
they're they're Half Baked
so much going on at Odd Socks uh so many
dope licenses man shout out to uh they
got Cheetos they got Jaws [__] Oreos
Cheech and Chong Naruto WWE by the way
WrestleMania is coming I can't wait to
see what dope WrestleMania socks they do
this year because last year they knocked
it out the park at Odd Socks look the
most comfortable socks in the world they
got The Odd Socks Basics that you need
on your feet uh all you got to do is go
to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg at checkout
you'll save 20 off your total order
underwear socks
[__] hats whatever you need they got it
at Odd Socks uh they just got the
Coca-Cola deal so you go get some
Coca-Cola drawers Coca-Cola socks so
much always going on in Odd Socks I'm
gonna always say my favorites are the
WWE in the Breaking Bad Ones
um so go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you will
save 20 off at checkout shout out to
them most comfortable socks in the world
crazy comfortable underwear my goodness
if you ain't got Odd Socks on your feet
and ass what are you doing out in these
streets all right go to
hotsocksofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off let's get back to the
interview
um
did you see little Wayne Rolling loud
uh
I just watched it on YouTube
the sound guy was [__] up the whole
saying all right let's see atrocious man
what's your favorite little Wayne album
uh card two card two or three
yeah Carter two is the right answer but
I also feel like Have you listened to
the card or two recently uh no not
recently to be honest I have to go back
I actually feel like the Carter 2 didn't
age as well as we all think it did
because I listened to it recently and I
was like
yeah I don't think this aged as well as
I had hoped I think I think I think
Carter 3 age way better yeah for sure
Carter Ford gospel Beggars on there too
got some good singles not the greatest
album though yeah Carter five
forgettable awesome awesome like awesome
like wordplay [__] also worship wordplay
shape part for like crazy
then being mixtape Wheezy though oh yeah
for sure not yeah
nip was that guy though man shout out to
nip do you feel like you kind of take a
lot of the [__] from like because you
know Nipsey obviously business minded
you know all about owning his own [__]
like you're opening restaurants or the
dispensary plays got to be big for you
man yeah yeah for sure to be able to
like legally sell weed in your city yeah
like I'm just I'm just I'm just an
investor in it but
is it pretty like is it a difficult
business to get involved in
uh
I think there's a lot of paperwork
behind it a lot of permits and a lot of
got to get approved by the city and
stuff like that so you can help curate
the bud that gets sold like you got to
get your own strain in that [__]
yeah for surely how do you not have a
strain yet
I don't know something I just never
pursued but everybody tell me this every
time bro you'll get it there's so many
weed companies that will give you a
strain bro everybody keeps telling me
that especially up north bro yeah
just get a nice little royalty check
every month yeah I just never I just
never was like
really pressed on it because like I
don't be smoking so like I just don't be
thinking about that [__] right but but
not everybody be telling me that for
sure like I'll be busy you don't smoke
never or you just always have not smoked
no I smoked before I was just what made
you quit
I just don't like how it makes me feel
you think you're more focused when
you're not high yeah for sure yeah
have you ever I don't know like I get I
get like super bad anxiety and like like
paranoid like I get like let me get
weird have you ever ate shrooms yeah my
shoes before how'd that go
uh I was I was like out the way when I
when I when I tried it the first time
that's how you're supposed to do it is
out there it is out the way but I mean
it was cool then it gets weird when you
start over it just makes me overthink it
that's the whole point of it yeah yeah
it just makes you like unravel your
brain and like
so the visual part though is cool
actually crazy yeah for sure lights look
all wild and [__] did you like you
didn't like trip like did you like see
[__] that wasn't there so I was tripping
for sure I forgot I forgot where I was
at I was I was staring down looking at
the Rocks for like five minutes straight
yeah I'm like what the [__]
but you but the Rocks weren't like they
didn't like turn into like animals and
like look at you back or like no that it
was a show it was doing something it was
like it was making shapes all type of
[__] check you out man shrooming hard
yes the shrooms are the new wave man
everyone I heard the film chocolates the
the uh what's it called the uh
what's them called
shroom chocolates they're gummies I mean
you're talking about there's like
chocolate bars yeah
yeah
everybody be off to I gotta give you
some gummies
I got the shrimp gummies for you oh for
real yeah I got my own [__] yeah we're
about to put you on man oh yeah we
should be taking like like two two
pieces or something yeah it depends on
what kind of day you're trying to have
it depends on if you want to look at
rocks for five minutes or not
or if you want to like be productive
yeah if you want to be productive I'll
do one or two but if you want to like
you know get serious I just eat the
whole [__] bag man but you gotta be
out the way yeah it should sure be yeah
you got to be out the way uh when is the
album coming out obviously the mixtape
or the ep's coming on the 17th right
yeah so I'm trying to trying to see if
you get it out by me or
on like no like I said no day I'm not
too sure but just as soon as I can I
just want to keep pushing music out
who's been the uh one artist or person
that you've been a fan of that like kind
of reached out to you or you realize was
like following what you were doing that
kind of caught you off guard
uh
I can't even think of top my head
because uh oh pnb Rock reached out one
time that's crazy awesome random ass
[__]
all right Peter
but yeah he reached out
um followed me
and then uh he was actually he asked he
asked me if I was signed are you trying
to sign you yeah I think that's what it
was because uh the conversation was
going back and forth and where I told
him I was with uh I was signed he kind
he kind of fell back ah yeah that's kind
of I mean
I feel like that happens a lot it's like
well [__] I I'm signed but like what's
up you feel like with my [__] let's work
you know yeah do you has that happened
has any other artists try to sign you
uh
no not not that I could think of to be
honest yeah
oh uh uh young did early early on who uh
young super young oh stupid young I
tried to sign up early early on like
early in my career
uh
I told bro I appreciate the opportunity
bro I was like I was in a mindset where
I'm trying to build your own [__] yeah
that's big man that's Proto what do you
think is the key to kind of stopping
some of this violence happening in
Stockton
or is it even possible
not possible you think it's possible I
don't think so like
like
it ain't no turning back once life is
lost you feel me no matter who you is or
what the circumstances is we're like
what's people once lives are gone it's
it's like it's just a cycle of non-stop
lives being lost because yeah
you don't think it takes somebody coming
in and being like hey well people have
been lost on both sides
it it even if that does work it's going
to be somebody on one side to uh
you feel me to to [__] it up yeah
well that's fair man we'll listen bro uh
EP come in the 17th what's it called
again
I started himself started in the South
album coming hopefully by May with big
features
big features Big features
can't tell us who though
um
give me some Clues man and then if I can
guess
just give me two Clues they could be the
most generic Clues ever
it's just down south
all right I need a second clue
give me a city don't just say down south
I'm gonna say between Atlanta and
Memphis
or probably I don't know
it's a terrible Clues
giving me nothing but
well look I can't wait to hear a man I
appreciate you pulling up uh go stream
the this guy's whole catalog because he
owns that [__] you know what I'm saying
where can they buy the merch
oh mbnl.com marquee.com go buy some
merch a tour soon you're gonna be
hitting the road doing any show soon uh
I was on that tour when I uh when I did
London and stuff like that the little
world tour but
but it's it's kind of on hold because
that Canada [__]
damn I had I had uh I had three shows in
uh it's Canada I had one in Toronto one
Montreal one in Vancouver Vancouver
supposed to kick it off
I [__] up the bag [__] it up customs
enemy shows was almost sold out damn
near sold out that's crazy bro well look
I appreciate you pulling up go follow
the homie you already know nbnail uh and
uh man keep keep doing your thing Bro
you've been killing it appreciate
watching it for a while so there it is
appreciate you